moe's mother sanzi got to come out with
fans in the stands at camden to throw
out a ceremonial first pitch
in honor of her absolutely amazing son
jorge lopez will as you can see win for
the third
time he already got down below six runs
a game
and miguel rojas sharply hit that one
off the glove of urias
and into center field one on one out for
aguilar
aguilar with a fly ball out to left
center field this one is hit deep
and it's off the top of the wall rojas
coming around
third relay not made and aguilar didn't
miss a two run home run by that much
and that is going to bring up brian
anderson who has been good to see him
back in the lineup really hasn't skipped
a beat
one and two from lopez hit on the ground
right side that'll get through for a
base hit aguilar
is coming around third throw from right
is a little bit late and aguilar is in
there an rbi single for brian anderson
[Applause]
diaz takes a pitch up and away so a walk
for lopez another base runner for the
marlins a high
baltimore chop that dies behind the
mound
infield single there for alfaro marlins
have him loaded
and brittson started to swing and did he
go
yes he did it was a breaking ball called
at home played
by todd tickster jordan holloway this
will be his 13th game this season his
fourth start
there's another hit doesn't matter
that's his first game and
against the orioles and therefore his
first start on this mound that is his
first
strikeout miguel rojas chops one
fair ball down the left field line this
should be extra bases for miggy
he'll cruise into second base with a
one-out double
and issan diaz fly to center in the
first inning
and he'll step in here
at least that is off the glove of leyva
trickles into right field and it's an
rbi single for isan diaz and the marlins
take a three-nothing lead here in the
second
and now it's aguilar who hit one to left
center field his first time up when
aguilar fly ball he's gonna try it again
out there in left center this time it's
gone
two run home run hey zeus
aguilar tattoos one and the marlins open
up a five to nothing lead this is low
and it's his second walk 12 runs this
series
and not even 11 innings marias gobbles
it up great play
and the orioles get the force out six to
four
there's a nice play in the middle in
field made by ramona rios
[Applause]
and he gets wild there's the first walk
of the night for baltimore
stewart is aboard with his 28th walk
ball fourth pedro severino up to the
plate
and severino has been producing runs
recently for the orioles
that ball is cracked to center field by
severino sierra at the wall
and it's gone
dead center field pedro
semmerino clubs a three-run jack
and the orioles are right back in the
game middle of the orioles order due up
mancini mount castle in stuart
that ball belt did no chance this is
staying in the park
trey has done it again
that's six games in a row with an
extra base hit the home run derby never
stops for trey mancini and the o's are
within one
there is sunsei gabba there's moe's mom
we all know how close trey
and mo were and there's mo blowing a
kiss trey talking to her in the crowd
after the home run i mean that is
amazing
well david has he's going to throw
anywhere in the mid 90s with that
fastball he's got a slider and a change
up
ramon urias will bat here in the bottom
of the third
maria santuo up the alley and left
center field the orioles have tied this
game
urrias into second stuart scores after
the pass ball
from second and in the blink of an eye
miami's five-nothing lead has been fully
erased we're
five five in the third
and that's a big pick up aguilar walks
back-to-back three passes issued by
eshelman
to start the fourth
and duvall in the left that one will
fall for a base hit
and they'll hold esan marlins have him
loaded
nobody out he has given up at least an
earned run in each of the first five
and this time anderson hit by the pitch
for real i think the lead back to the
marlins
ureas making the play marlins or diaz
rather was facing the ship there
and maria's made the play he'll get
credit for the rbi on the
ground out so tying run here in the
fifth dj stewart
and stewart out to right field duval
turns he'll have to play it off the wall
mount castle on his way to third he gets
the green light throw from miggy
is in time
alfaro had to go out and get it reach
back and got mount
castle
[Applause]
mullins fly ball center field sends
sierra back
near the wall looks like he'll have just
enough room
hit hard andy there side saddles it and
fires over to first base
wow make it three and 38 in the third
innings
what an at-bat off the bench for mckenna
maria's into right field though and this
is a hit for ramon
ryan mckenna great runner to third
mckenna with a stop sign urrias in the
second
big time double on an o2 pitch and the
orioles had the tying runs in scoring
position with only one out
the batter is pedro severino they've got
a shift on behind
bleyer sebarino goes to the right side
and diaz will get the out at first
mckenna got about halfway down the line
throw to third gets away and ryan will
get up and dash home
oh mckenna all the way home
after the throw from diaz was not caught
and once again ryan mckenna's speed
creates a
major problem and a tying run at third
with michael franco batting and this
ball is grounded through the vacant
right side the orioles have tied it in
the eighth
inside a four-pitch walk and that's how
the ninth inning starts go ahead and run
out at first base
and this one is chopped slowly up the
third base line tate
bear hands it but has no play and the
marlins have the first two runners on
well tanner scott comes in 13.17
strikeouts per nine innings that's the
highest of any of the relievers
there is a good slider and a tapper
urias gets one that's the only one he'll
get as sierra runs
so well there is no chance for two
this is a ground ball to third franco
will go to
first in the inning
[Applause]
it is a lead-off walk for cedric mullins
the game-winning run
is aboard in the ninth with nobody out
takes his lead
that one gets away and cedric will go to
second base a
very wild pitch from ochre outfield very
shallow
now austin will lay down a bunt alfaro
grabs it in fair territory
and the orioles have the winning run at
third base
90 feet away hallelujah the double
intentional walk for don mattingly
he will set up a force everywhere and
put the game in the hands of ryan
mckenna
a 3-2 with the bases loaded is in the
dirt and the orioles
literally walk it off
ryan mckenna the hero two walks
in two innings off the bench and in a
four
walk ninth inning the orioles have come
from
five runs down to shock the marlins